it all began for a Coldplay in the
mid-1990s when the band members met at
University College London for their
first mini album only 500 copies were
pressed but their next album parachutes
released in 2000 brought them
international attention
the single clocks from 2002 with their
distinctive melodies the Brits stormed
the charts worldwide
Oh
the band have always liked to take their
time with each record challenging
themselves to try new sounds and
directions
as a feeling of are we pushing hard
enough are things as good as they can be
are we trying new things or are we
relying on old ideas that we're
recycling
that love of experimenting has paid off
both in album sales and awards the 2008
single Viva la Vida was Coldplay's first
number-one hit in both the u.s. and the
UK and won the Grammy Award for song of
the year they've also made a name for
themselves for their charity work such
as campaigning for the British
organization Oxfam if the past is
anything to go by this latest release is
sure to build on Coldplay's popularity
and success
you